nice is a jewel on the french riviera
holidaymakers flocked to the city
renowned for its mild mediterranean
climate the promenade des anglais is a
landmark in Nice the seven kilometer
long walkway is named after British
tourists who proposed and financed its
construction in the 19th century
imposing buildings line the route from
Ned is only a promenade des anglais is
very important to nice it became a
glamorous place in the 19th century the
place where grand hotels were built and
rich visitors came for spar holidays the
walkway became niece's showcase and an
entire district grew up around it the
promenade Nate needs famous sparking a
trend now known around the globe as
tourism a villa complete madiha noman
model moco news on Twitter too with this
stretch of coastline was just a pebbly
beach until wealthy British vacationers
financed the construction of the
promenade opened in 1824 it made nice a
tourist destination luxury hotel
Negresco is the most famous building
along the promenade built in the style
of the Belle époque it opened its doors
in 1912 the course a liar market in the
old town is an institution in Nice held
daily it's the city's oldest market
vendors have been selling their wares
here for over 150 years the market is
also famous for its colorful flowers
which inspired artists like owned by
Matisse and mock sugar journalist Petra
hull has been coming here for many years
yeah upton mark from course here at the
course alia market many things come
together wonderful sense aroma's colors
mixed together they create a
Mediterranean Flair that the artists
found irresistible then optical and here
they also found the motifs they needed
for their artwork on food easy for her
back at all moksha Kyle painted many
pictures of nice they can be seen at the
National Museum which bears the artists
now
over 400 of his works are on display
here making it the world's largest sugar
collection open to the public
gosh I gotta do Kubelik would desert
moksha guy discovered the code Azul in
1926 he was dazzled by all the flowers
at the market he returned after the
Second World War after living in exile
in America he lived here from 1948 until
his death in 1985 he was inspired by the
region's light and the colors Lisa's old
town dates back more than 2,000 years
it's winding alleyways and pastel
colored buildings resemble those of
Italian towns and they wonder until it
was annexed by France over a century and
a half ago nice still belong to the
kingdom of Sardinia good accent when I'd
say it's a good since eighteen sixty
nice the county of nice because it's the
whole region from here to malta has
belonged to France ah but Italian
culture Italian cuisine and the Italian
dialect have been retained here and you
can sense that everywhere well this is
you guys feel bad nieces port district
has recently become hip new parks have
been created like this one there plus
Messina nieces main square young
entrepreneurs have also moved in and
opened up trendy boutiques and
restaurants like contour central
electrique two years ago it was still an
electronic store until German chef
Carlos transformed it into nieces
hottest Bistro did you ma'am ma'am
humanoid an district is drawing more and
more young people increasingly
restaurants bars designer stores are
opening up here finally safi lecrea TV a
lot of really creative people come here
and go after them Robin our skin here
the nicest view of the city can be had
from the calendar shuttle the 92 meter
high hill took part lies between the old
town and the port far-off knows it's the
nicest place in Nice
vespa Thunder is the Aussie the best
things that you your niece flies at your
feet at any time of the day and at night
do when you come here everything's lit
up it's just stunning how often do the
Colleen duchateau doesn't just post the
best view / nice it's also the place
where this jewel of the French Riviera
was once founded